If you said these two, excellent work. For monomials, we said that the exponent
needs to be non-negative, so that means the exponent must be positive or zero.
Here are two examples where the exponent in the monomial is negative, so these
aren't monomials. This term is negative, but the variable, or n, appears in the
denominator. Any expression or term with a variable in the denominator isn't a
monomial. These two examples are the same, the b appears in the denominator, and
the x appears in the denominator, so these can't be monomials. You might not
have gotten this reason right, which is totally okay, it turns out that a square
root can be written as x to the one half, we haven't even covered this topic
yet, so if you got that right, that's amazing. We'll see this fractional
exponent, later but I just wanted to preview it now. We do know that monomials
can be the product of two variables and that they can be positive or negative,
these are the real reasons, why all of these weren't examples of monomials.